you're famous for your impressions or
impressions can you do an impression of
Kanye talking to Taylor Swift Wow
whoo okay you know what it's kind of
hilarious that you know I'm the reason
that you're actually there but you know
you want to give me my credit dial I
mean but you know we are friends for
real hey that's fit that's what he was
saying straight up
it's fun oh man no hyperventilate tell
you when so it sound like he drownded
you don't say it's like it's a pool
around him and he keeps drowning almost
and he's a psych almost did it but I
didn't Dido cuz you know I got more
words to get to the world you know
because I'm just that special you know
I'm that special you know you know I'm
like I'm like you know actually you know
I'm like adding you know extra you know
sour cream Leo burrito you know you got
it that's something special right there
my impression of Taylor is now I'm gonna
go home and cry to my cat oh that was a
very nice person
don't say I love you Taylor social
bullying need to stop shut out the
Leslie Jones bagel yeah what was your
reaction and yeah Berlin first of all
that's my friend people need to leave
her alone she is a sweet funny talented
person and she's been in the game since
I was born she started doing comedy when
I was born so that was 87 at 28 years
ago I'm about to be 29 but I'm 28 dang
she's been doing comedy for that long so
leave alone man and high respect for
Leslie exactly if she deserves she
deserves all over her success for real